الحقيقه الاوكرانيين يعني
ينظرون الى الحاله العامه بذات الطريقه
التي ينظر اليها فلاديمير ذات الروح هي
تسود في بين ابناء الشعب الاوكراني هم
ينظرون الى العام الماضي كعام مضى بكل
الامه وانهم استطاعوا ان يقفوا في هذا
العام يقولون انه لم يتوقع احد ان تصمت
كيف ولكن الاوكرانيين اتهشوا العالم
بصمودهم خطاب زيليسكي كان خطابا مؤثرا لم
يترك شارده ولا وارده مما حدث في العام
الماضي الا وتطرق اليها لم يترك فئه او
جهه او شخص لم يخاطبه خاطب زيلينسكي جميع
فئات المجتمع الاوكراني تحدث الى
المتطوعين وانت عادل كنت هنا وعايشت
الفتره الاولى للحرب وتعلم جيدا دور
المتطوعين في عمليه الصمود للشعب
الاوكراني ويعني حل كثير من المشاكل عن
طريق المتطوعين خاطب المواطنين الذين
يقبعون الان في تلك المناطق والاراضي التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا ووصفها بالاراضي
المحتله وقال ان اوكرانيا لم تنساكم ولن
تنساكم وما زلنا نعمل لاعادتكم الى حضن
الوطن ايضا
خاطب من يعملون الان وعادوا الى البلاد
ويعملون في الوظائف للمحافظه على الاقتصاد
وخاطب اولئك الذين هم خارج البلاد وقال
سوف نعمل بجهد على تحرير الاراضي لتعودوا
الى دياركم بامان تطرق ايضا الى كل
الاحداث الهامه في العام الماضي احداث
وايضا يعني حصار العاصمه كيف لم يترك شيء
وكان خطابا مؤثرا جدا هذا من ناحيه الخطاب
ولكن ايضا الوضع هنا في العاصمه منذ الامس
اختلف كثيرا عادل لو لديك مكان مزيد من
الوقت ساحدثك عن كيف انتظر الاوكرانيون
هذا اليوم ساعود اليك لنتحدث ساذهب الى
رائد الاغبر رائد يعني ما بين الامس
واليوم ايضا تغير لديك على الجبهه الكثير
ولكن منذ بدايه هذه الحرب الى اليوم كانت
ربما معارك بعضها سهله بالنسبه للروس
وبعضها صعبه جدا لم تحسن تلك المعارك كيف
هي الاوضاع لديك وكيف ينظر سكان دونسك على
الاقل الى استمرار هذه الحرب
بدايه عادل لابد من الاشاره الى ان هذا هو
العام التاسع للمعارك هنا في دانيتك وليس
اكمال عام لان هذه المنطقه شهدت منذ عام
معارك ضاريه وقصف مستمر خلال كل تلك
الفتره حتى هذه الساعه وروسيا دخلت في هذه
المعركه في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
الماضي من اجل حمايه المواطنين الروس
الذين يقتنون الشرق الاوكراني كما تقول
موسكو اليوم
بوشيلين زعيم الانفصاليين هنا قال بان
النصر بالتاكيد سيكون حليفنا رغم دعم
الغرب بكل الادوات للسلطات الاوكرانيه
واغراقها اكثر في هذه الحرب الداميه في
الصباح التقينا مع بعض المواطنين الذين
عبروا عن رغبتهم بانهاء هذه المعارك
ورغبتهم بالسلام دائما كلمه السلام تكون
هي عنوان اي حديث يمكن ان يجمعنا مع
المواطنين لكن يتلوه الشكر لروسيا التي
تقف الى جانبهم بعد 9 سنوات كامله من
القصف المستمر الذي يخلف ضحايا بشكل يومي
يوم امس قصف اوكراني بصواريخ هايمرز على
قلب المدينه خلف سته اصابات
وثلاثه عفوا سته قتله و 13 اصابه والقصف
مستمر منذ الصباح الباكر ارتفعت وتيره
القصف المتبادل عادل لابد ان هناك عمليه
عسكريه كبيره يحضر لها الطرفين قبل مارس
اذار المقبل طيب قبل ان اذهب الى عبد
الجواد الرشد استاذنك لاذهب الى الوافد
الجديد الى هذه الساعه وهما احمد بجاتو
بعد اذنك يعني عبد الجواد احمد بقاتو
كصحفي وبعين المتلمس لكل ما هو جديد انت
يعني ذهبت الى اوكرانيا
هذه السنه او في نهايه العام الاول من
الحرب كيف ترى الاوضاع حيث انت من يعني من
لديك من كراماتوريسك وبالتالي
يعني سكان تلك المناطق كيف ينظرون الى عدم
انتهاء هذا الصراع
نعم اهلا عادل بك بالزملاء يعدعنا نتحدث
يعني اربعه ايام
لي هنا في اوكرانيا باربع مدن مختلفه كيف
خاركيف
ايزيوم وكذلك في المنطقه التي تسيطر عليها
او تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه بالطبع
الاغلب هذه المنطقه والمقاطعه تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه هناك حاله من الخوف الشديد
خلال هذه الايام من قبل الكثير من
المواطنين الذين يرون ان مع قدوم فصل
الربيع ربما تحاول القوات الروسيه الهجوم
بصوره اعنف واقوى هناك كان هناك حديث
بصوره مستمره عن الذكرى الاولى الحرب حتى
القياده العسكريه هنا تتحدث ان الذكرى
الاولى الحرب قد تشهد هجمه قويه خاصه في
المناطق هنا في دنيتك كلمان
وكذلك ايضا بخموت بخموت نحن قريبين للغايه
منها يعني اسمع القصف بوضوح وبعد ذلك يكون
هناك صافرات الانذار ربما ونحن نتحدث يحدث
ذلك دعني ايضا اتحدث لك عن الوضع في بخموت
بخموت الان هذه المدينه التي كان يسكنها
اكثر من سبعين الف شخص الان يتواجد فيها
حوالي ثلاثه الاف شخص فقط لا يوجد اي شخص
يمشي في الشوارع الان القوات الروسيه
تحاول بشتى الطرق السيطره على هذه المدينه
في اسرع وقت ممكن تقوم الان الان القوات
الروسيه بتطويق او محاوله تطويق القوات
الاوكرانيه الموجوده وفقا لمصادر العسكريه
الاوكرانيه التي تتحدث عن ان الهجوم
الروسي ياتي من ثلاث جهات الجهه الشماليه
والجهه الشرقيه والجهه الجنوبيه وصلت
القوات الروسيه او تحاول الهجوم من الجهه
الشماليه وصلت الى محطه القطار الرئيسيه
وكذلك ايضا منطقه المصانع من الجهه
الشرقيه تحاول الوصول الى مركز المدينه
وان تسيطر على مبنى الحكم المحلي هناك
وهذا سيمثل نصرا كبي بالنسبه اليها ومن
الجهه الجنوبيه وصلت الى منطقه المقابر في
بخموت يعني التقدم هو تقدم
تحاوله تحاول قوات الروسيه التقدم بصوره
سريعه لكن من الجهه الاخرى القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول انها تصد هذه الهجمات نحو
تحدث منذ الانس وحتى صباح هذا اليوم اكثر
من 100 هجوم روسيا القوات العسكريه او
الجيش الاوكرانيه يقول انه صد معظم هذه
الهجمات وايضا هناك استخدام مستمر
للطائرات المسيره الروسيه لمعرفه او تحديد
بصوره اكثر دقه تحديد اماكن تمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه ومن ثم توجيه المدفعيه لتقوم
باستهدافها بصوره اكثر بصوره اكبر نعم
احمد ساعود اليك لكن دعني اذهب الى عبد
الجواد الرشد عبد الجواد يعني بعد مرور
هذا العام هذه الحرب كان ينظر اليها انها
قد تكون حرب او عمليه عسكريه خاطفه تنجز
بها القوات الروسيه مهامها ولكن طالما
امدها وبالتالي البعض حتى شكك بمقدره
القوات الروسيه على انهاء هذه الحرب اليوم
الروس كيف ينظرون الى امتداد هذا الحرب
على مدى عام الى اليوم وخاصه انه يعني بعد
قليل سنعرض صور لاستقلال استونيا اللي هو
يصادف الذكرى او انفصالها عن روسيا في
الرابع والعشرين من هذا الشهر كما نشاهد
الان ذكرى
ذكرى استقلال استونيا عن القوات البلشفيه
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
1918 هذا هو يوم الاستقلال وهو اليوم
الوطني في استونيا عبد الجواد
اعود اليك حرب
كان لها ان تكون
خاطفه او عمليه عسكريه كان لها ان تكون
خاطفه لكنها استمرت الى فتره طويله هل
الراي كذلك التخوف بدا يدوب في قلوب الروس
ام انهم مطمئنون تفضل
مرحبا عادل لك ولي الزملاء صحيح ما تقول
هي تقارير غربيه وتقارير محليه كانت قد
تحدثت قبل سنه من الان عن ان هذه العمليه
العسكريه ستكون لعده ايام وان موسكو ستكون
قادره على حسم الصراع في ايام معدوده طبعا
المشهد كما تحدث الكثير من قراء يعني
خبراء السياسه في البلاد بان المعركه الان
تحولت الى صراع كبير بين موسكو في الشرق
وبين الغرب بشكل كبير هي معركه طبعا طالت
الاخضر واليابس في جنوب الاوكراني وطالت
اقتصاديا وطالت الوضع الروسي في الداخل
بشكل كبير عقوبات اقتصاديه عقوبات على
كافه الاشكال حظر على العديد من الامور
لذلك طبعا عمليه الهجره التي قام بها بعض
المواطنين الروس من الداخل نحو دول اخرى
هي ملحوظه بشكل كبير عنصر الذي افتقد نوعا
ما من الشارع الروسي ايضا يلاحظ بشكل كبير
ان كان هذا الشيء في موسكو وان كان في
ميسك او بعض المدن البيلاروسيه لذلك طبعا
هي حرب كبيره طبعا لن تنتهي لا بيوم ولا
بيومين تعرف عادل اننا منذ ايام تحدثنا
وكان لنا حوار طويل مع الكسندر دوجن وهو
العقل المفكر الذي بنى على افكاره
سياسته في توحيد الاوراسيا طبعا يتحدث عن
ان هذا الصراع كبير ولا مجال لروسيا في
الهزيمه فيه باعتبار ان الهزيمه ستقوم
بتشتيت روسيا
وتفريقتها بشكل كبير الحرب مستمره كما يرى
دوجن طبعا عادل معظم الشاشه في العالم
يتحدثون عن ان النصر سيكون من نصيب
حلفائهم الا بلاروس التي اقف فيها في
الوقت الحالي بلا روسيا طبعا تقع في يعني
بين نارين نار حليفتها موسكو والاخ الاكبر
التي تربطها بها والحليف السياسي والعسكري
الكبير ونار الاخوه العرقيه مع الشعب
الاوكراني باستثناء طبعا الصراع السياسي
بين حكومه بيلاروسيا وحكومه اوكرانيا
طبعا اصلاح الامور قدمت اراضيها لكن طبعا
كل هذه المحاولات فشلت عادل خلال هذا
العام بشكل كبير الاراضي البيلاروسيه لم
تعد عادل كما كانت عليه قبل عام من الان
ايضا يعني عليها الكثير من العقوبات يعني
قدمت اراضيها لموسكو للدخول الى الاراضي
الاوكرانيه قدمت اجوائها لطيران وتحليق
المقاتلات وفي نقطه اخيره عادل لو سمحت لي
الرئيس البيلاروسي تحدث قبل اسبوع بان لو
موسكو عادت وطلبت الاراضي البيلاروسيه
للدخول الاراضي الاوكرانيه فسيقدمها
بالتاكيد يعني سنكون معك عبد الجواد ومع
احمد بقاتو في سياق هذه التغطيه في هذه
الساعه تحديدا ولكن الشكر موصول لجميع
مراسلينا حذيفه عادل من كيب وكذلك من
كراماتورس مراسل العربيه احمد باجاتو
ومراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر من
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد يعني
دائما اتمنى لكم السلامه حيث كنتم وتعودون
الينا دائما سالمين غانمين ولكن قلبي مع
احمد بقاتو يعاني البرد ضعفكم تقريبا